you to say squeeze et hybrid est enfin
là le nouveau jeu de mecs qui ont fait
sur john simulator nous sommes donc une
tranche de pain de mie et pas de pain
non me sentais très important ça il ya
un an du calendrier on est lundi ces
parties où j'ai bien la musique derrière
très entraînant c'est à voilà là d'un
coup c'est beaucoup moins d'entraîneurs
que je tranche de pomme
alors on y va ou alors j'ai aucune idée
ce qui est le but je crois qu'il faut
que la tranche de pain de mie soit la
plus délicieuse possible et si on n'est
pas un endroit qui convient pas trop
loin ni par exemple le sol de la cuisine
on perd des points par des de la barre
des 10 bility en haut à gauche
bien sûr c'est très maniable 1 tout
comme sur jeunes simulate un serment les
jeux extrêmement maniable 1,33 dans la
confiture fetwa masser par la confiture
à la musique qui s'emballe et où danse
de tartines 1 1 1
je pense qu'il faut se faire tester en
grippant et où l'avoir regardée aux
hôpitaux il est bien à l'opposé de la ou
des bordels gérés à une tartine de pain
se touchent tout seul si le matin c'est
vraiment bien j'aimerais beaucoup la
voir comme ça se déplacer un peu comme
ça de manière élégante
oui le beurre est à moi très musclé à
cette tartufferie vous l'avez qu elle
vraiment sc 1 contre l'as mais ça c'est
à ça joue sur l'aîné h contre avec les
pieds et les petites fesses de babouins
là que j'ai mais je pense qu'ils vont se
tartiner après cette fête au stella
onssa couple de manière bien gracieuse
avec ce beurre mais bon je pense qu'à ça
tisse est tombé là dessus voilà est donc
surtout show soria et reste pas par
terre c'est pape rabat je peux ce skate
n'est pas là pour rien oui on peut on
préfère du skate mon gars oui c'est
ridicule c'est totalement ridicule mais
il ya de grandes sensations vraiment
merci skateboard non attention pas tout
gâcher non mais qu'est ce tu fais ce qu
apporte surtout pas tomber attention
bosse bosse au [ __ ] déjà tartine mon
gars et là ça vaut le coup de sifflet
pour ce jeu parce que [ __ ] on a un
objectif clair et net mais on va y
arriver à les bâtards t'il pas de
l'autre côté prend de l'élan aux dix
sept tranches de parts sera toaster
comme il s'occupe de se fixer des
objectifs aussi pourri quoi nous devons
au stella tranche ne pas nous ne vivons
que pour ça voilà où obtenant puisse pas
trop allez-vous-en cap la saulaie mon
territoire
to be en tartine je te montrerai que je
suis plus fort que toi tour peut être
monté dessus au tour comment tu as pu
faire ça qu'on va faire ça je sois frigo
nom remonte vite c'est bon on remonte on
est sorties d'affaires
non ça me temps ça me tente j'imaginais
de m'accuser pour une tartine comme ça
qu'ils escaladent nous quittons plus je
sais sur sauveur je laisse au vrai que
ma bouche
ah qu'est ce qui se passe tous non non
non stop
on est presque au tien bo thiam on
tartine tient bon on n'est pas du tout
prêt seront autant non je n'ai pas menti
je préfére repérer des gens d'en charger
une cible à tort vraiment j'insiste
cette fois ils ont mis une musicale
avengers en fout quoi juste une tartine
de pas arrêter parce que du coup je suis
bon pour givet en rampant et là
attention au moment de mourir
hop je nous sommes au fait j avais cru
je prenais pour super tartines et où
elle était délicieuse
elle avait un point de délicieuses
naissent voilà allez dégagez les bouts
de verre marc yevou
calme-toi elle met la pression cette
tartine j'aurais jamais imaginé qu'une
tartine ne mettrait la pression comme ça
elle sait que ses confitures ta joue
boys j'avais sûrement pas fait voler
tuer sa meute en ce genre de jeu qui ta
g mais j'y vais on y va oh [ __ ]
c'était non non a jusqu'à la plus grande
partie de tous les temps sur un toaster
être ici je me frotte un peu au mondial
s'est rattrapé n'ont d'autant pas
tartine tu peux t'en sortir je te
promets arrête tu me fait vomir caméra
et là bas
ah bah allez fausses bon ça se fait
qu'on a perdu de l'égibilité qu'on était
sur la table lors des liens tout pas bon
assez du poivre du sel ça à en jouer
avec le feu aux joues avec le vide je
dirais belge est plus approprié pour
tout lâcher quand c'est comme ça non ah
je sais on va faire dans la largeur
voilà comme ça qu'à 2 1 3 à mes [ __ ]
de tours de merde
elle a mis à mal notre stratégie au plan
n'a pas le temps on ces conneries c'est
ray allen ou non c'est très compliqué
non non non non oh [ __ ]
non non non non ça c'est l'endroit gaudy
non nous laisse pas dans cet endroit
maudit on finira dans ce tout ce que
vous le vouliez ou non meubles et divers
objets de la cuisine d'un vous n'êtes
pas vivante toi ma tartine je t'aime
tellement toi ma tartine et confiance en
moi je fais une chanson d'amour pour une
tarte il ya un problème au yes un [ __ ]
x lite tout là bas
ayala lydia choix que tu tombes dans la
litière de l'animal deux assists
alimente à tartiner explose finalement
[ __ ] j'ai l'impression ou faut me
dépression' et dépression' et moi s'il
vous plaît non en tout doux on est bon
on est bon on est bon
toi papa de panique faut garder son
calme surtout c'est important regardez
en bas ce piège-là la gamelle du chien
ou du chien là il faut se lancer il faut
sentir n'a pas le choix
foster n'a pas le choix en plein we hope
la wii
ah ah non non j'en bon temps complet
merci bouteille je suis ne l'a jamais de
sa tête que tu m'as apporté aux vous
avez vu ça oh la la la stratégie ohlala
alors là alors là tous les objets qui
m'ont aidé et je me souviendrai de vous
quand je serai président des tartines
parce que ça arrivera un jour faites moi
confiance je serai le maître incontesté
des tartines de france je prévois aussi
d'être le maître incontesté tartine de
russie voilà ce qu'ils mangent du pain
avec la vodka
êtes vous prêt pour la plus belle
acrobatie de tous les a mais attendez
attendez attendez je trouvais nos
techniques si on passe par le mur la
droite regardez comme ça en mode un peu
agent secret passe par le mur du midi
connu attendant je vais pleurer
dépêche-toi du microbe microbienne oui
mais je vais pleurer ya la grippe a on
peut le voir on peut le voir attentats
n'ont jamais dire chanter la tarte et
excité au mont dieu on va dans le gris
pas mon gars et je crois pouvoir enfin
se faire tester
est-ce que c'est lui le plus beau jour
de ma vie la plus belle réussite à la
mêlée des mois aussi un peu en retrait
dans quand même puisque l'as ain on
attend d'un combo parfait non non
regardez il m'a bloqué il m'a dit non à
tuer jouera un homme et j'ai cassé le
grille pain
on peut tester au four on va tenter le
four échelle on y arrivera ok direction
ce qui attend nos échecs mais non mais
s'enfuit traite pas bien là je te
lâcherai i'm a donné à donald hince au
skateboard vous jure messi répond petite
tartine j'te ferai démolir tour quand je
serai le roi non non non non au voile
âge c'était oui moi même pas besoin
d'appeler quelqu'un pour faire ça
on règle nos problèmes nous-mêmes on est
autonome bientôt des gens sera désormais
trop par des tartines oui et alors tu es
chaud c'est chaud chantre j'ai le cul
entre deux chaises comme on dit dans le
milieu on y voir comme thierry henry
niester ton mission impossible dans
l'oeil un problème vous jure qu'on va se
faire tout sept-îles qc à pois fois que
j'ai pas envie qu'on se fasse toaster le
cul mais c'est pour la bonne cause vite
la barre 9e 1 à 0 on va devoir se
détache oui on est on y est presque on
non le grip le crypto gay pas lâcher l
évasif ours banao aa
ok dominicaine ni calories dans la boîte
de céréales
allez on fait la fête avait du coup
parfois la tartine va est délicieuse
après ça les connaît c'est carrément
trop nerveux ce jeu quoi ça te met dans
un état bosse et j'ai un plan
d'évacuation tels les commandants
lorsqu'ils font la guerre sauf que nous
on veut juste faire toaster c'est un peu
moins un peu moins de mérite
ah ah mais oui mais vas-y la tartine
serpillière mon gars j'avais pas vu
cette barre de grippe elle fait chier
non arrivant à tu vaut mieux que sa
tartine juste avait promis un futur
vraiment bien chez lui après quand je
m'habille et alors
oh ne surtout pas toucher l'eau en fait
il faut sauter mais ya ce truc là si on
tombe dedans je suis sûr qu'on perd
direct et à eybens et 3h et on a passé
ce site de tartes et mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fait c'est un symptôme peut plus
ça me tente rouge vous jure sa pop et un
l et es démissionner l'avait 195 points
de délicieuses nes je vous jure c'est le
temps c'est un truc de dingue quand tu
as envie de faire un truc mais qui se
passe tout à fait autre chose que tu es
là avec des petits doigts sur ton
clavier et je n'ai qu'une chose à dire
pour notre défense je ne manque jamais
de pain toasté et voilà le genre c'est
bien fin de cette vidéo j'ai ce soir ça
vous a plus ces cas n'hésitez pas aimé
la vidéo comme d'habitude hu a mangé une
tranche de parler ou l'autre comme vous
préférez pato stella tranches de pains
sinon vous des forces ont surtout
retrouvé dans une nouvelle vidéo c'était
un vrai job du monde pis
elle va
[Applaudissements]